[Music]
i can't eat anymore
i'm gonna pass out
hello my name is ada i am a senior video
producer at buzzfeed uk i live in london
but i'm from mani and my name is
manchester sorry i forgot that i'm not
talking to only brits hello
i'm going to show you
what i eat in a week
let's do it
[Music]
so let's kick it off with breakfast
i'm just gonna have cereal
i only eat one type of cereal which is
cheerios and
honey and yes i could just get honey
cheerios but it's not the same
with
lactose free milk because i am lactose
intolerant but you will see me eat dairy
this week because
i don't care for my life really
is
[Music]
so i've got some things to pick up from
the shop so i think i'm just going to
grab some sushi and have that for lunch
so sushi is
[Music]
is
um so it's actually me and my partner's
anniversary there he is
and we're going to a new restaurant
called norma
this is the pizza fritta
i appreciate this scallop thank you
and this is the wild boar ravioli
slow roasted lamb shoulder i'm some
cannoli
i can't eat anymore
i'm gonna pass out
it is 9 00 a.m and it's time for some
breakfast um i record a podcast forward
season sessions um and for that be
height i tend to not eat in the morning
because
i think hunger makes me shout
out
[Music]
says
i am a bit hungry now because i
i don't know my own body so i'm going to
get a brownie
to snack before we do the podcast
[Music]
[Music]
still quite full for my brownie but i
have a busy day ahead and i try to go
out this evening so
i'm getting jamaican food i'm going to
get the jerk of box with some plantain
because that's what i deserve
so i've got
jerk chicken
like
this is lush also i'm in the office some
plantains some jerk chicken and i think
there's like some salad and some hot
sauce
[Music]
little
[Music]
my boyfriend just gave me this
clementines with almonds with like some
christmas chocolate i'm not the person
to represent all brits but
you know
there's some others that still live like
this
and of course there's always a cup of
tea
mrs
one of the main benefits of living in
london is having all the different
cuisines so i'm going to get
the keeper fried chicken
i think
so we just got some pita bread and
hummus
and some calamari here
and now i'm back home obviously i have
to get straight on a cup of tea
[Music]
and continue with my working day
[Music]
is
[Music]
so for dinner i'm having ramen um all
i'm gonna add to is one egg
so i'm gonna boil an egg
so this is what i'm having and this is
the ugliest egg in the world because the
shell just wouldn't come off
[Music]
so i'm gonna get a pastry for me and my
partner because why not always be nice
to take it home to him
i've been surprised with a little miso
soup
cheers
[Music]
a nice pre-dinner snack
as i'm not as useless as i may seem so i
will be doing the potatoes
for the salmon
burgers yes
which will just be like
little wedgies with
you know oil salt and pepper nothing
too extravagant
we have the world's biggest salmon
burger
[Music]
question
[Music]
[Music]
so what i'm making for breakfast is like
a breakfast brew i think i saw kiana
they used to work on tasty maker and
it's like you know a tortilla with
plantain scrambled egg some sriracha
some avocado and some lardons
looks fantastic
[Music]
so my hair is done i'm at a friend's
house and we're going to have a roast
i'm super pumped a roast is super
important to british people the point of
a rose is to be over full
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i translate for you i'm the translator
of your book
why are all these people there i made
some changes
what have you done to my book
oh my lord i know